[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen sind sport hat
norbert könig für sie dort draußen steht
[Gelächter]
die wichtigen themen heute
dreimal ja zur ampel auch die fdp will
koalitionsgespräche mit spd und grünen
die liberalen sehen chancen aber auch
herausforderungen
wenn jeder liter zählt der steigende
ölpreis macht autofahren immer teurer
der tanktourismus an den grenzen blut
und leben im internet facebook will eine
neue virtuelle welt schaffen doch die
bedenken gegen das projekt sind groß
verhandlung für eine ampel koalition
steht nichts mehr im wege heute haben
sich auch fdp vorstand und fraktion
einstimmig dafür ausgesprochen die
koalitionsgespräche könnten bereits in
dieser woche beginnen einfach werden sie
aber nicht fdp chef lindner sagte es
gebe große inhaltliche unterschiede
zwischen spd grünen und fdp indes trams
mit den einzelheiten die fröhliche
euphorie der sondierungsphase scheint
vorbei ernst tritt fdp chef lindner auf
nach zweieinhalb stunden beratungen von
fraktionen und bundesvorstand klar ist
nun auch die liberalen sagen ja zur
aufnahme von koalitionsverhandlungen
deutschland benötigt eine umfassende
modernisierung von gesellschaft
wirtschaft und staat wir begeben uns nun
auf den weg verantwortung für
deutschland mit zu übernehmen
die ampel für lindner ein zweckbündnis
ob daraus mehr werden könne liege an den
beteiligten die gesprächspartnerinnen
und gesprächspartner haben sich vor der
bundestagswahl nicht gesucht
um es diplomatisch auszudrücken
es ist auch
keine überraschung dass es unverändert
das große inhaltliche unterschiede gibt
wenig sagt lindner zur finanzierbarkeit
der großen vorhaben die das
eckpunktepapier der verhandler festhält
ein klimaschutz sofortprogramm
digitalisierung ein stabiles
rentenniveau an das ohne
steuererhöhungen unter beibehaltung der
schuldenbremse waage auch die anderen
jetzt sind schon koalitions fahren und
dazu gehört auch ein kassensturz und da
werden wir noch mal insgesamt schauen
wie die finanzlage ist und welche
weiteren ausgaben finanzierbar sind es
geht auch um private investitionen die
wollen wir stimulieren es geht um die
frage wie wir planungs beschleunigung so
vorantreiben können das schnelle auch
geld zur verfügung steht also da ist ein
ganzes bündel an maßnahmen drin zum
tauziehen zwischen grünen und liberalen
um das wichtige finanzministerium äußert
sich lindner nicht doch der kampf um
macht und personalien beginnt nun in der
zweiten wochenhälfte könnte das erste
gespräch stattfinden
legen wir auf das thema das jetzt schon
so lange unser aller leben bestimmt die
pandemie seit märz 2020 gilt in
deutschland eine corona notlage diese
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
will bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
jetzt am 25 november auslaufen lassen
theo koll was bedeutet das nun das
bedeutet das ende der sogenannten
epidemischen lage die ja jetzt schon
seit über anderthalb jahren in
deutschland gilt mit dieser gesetzlichen
ausnahmeregelung konnte die
bundesregierung ja verordnung erlassen
mit massiven grundrechtseingriff wie
beispielsweise kontakt beschränkungen
oder ähnlich ist jens spahn geht
angesichts von mehr als 80 prozent der
erwachsenen jetzt nicht mehr davon aus
dass es in diesem herbst und winter zu
einer bundesweiten überlastung des
gesundheitswesens kommen wird allerdings
mit zwei einschränkungen die hygiene und
abstandsregeln sollen weiterhin gelten
das unterscheidet die aufhebung vom
sogenannten freedom day anderer länder
und in einem heutigen internen
lagebericht geht sparen davon aus dass
es regional bei niedrigen impfquoten
doch noch zu überlastungen des
gesundheitswesens kommen kann das müssen
dann aber die betroffenen bundesländer
selbst regeln danke für diese einordnung
theo koll
die aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland gehen weiter nach oben
innerhalb eines tages kamen 4056
neuinfektionen dazu
945 mehr als vor einer woche auch die
inzidenz steigt auf jetzt
74,7
eine folge der pandemie die grippewelle
ist letzte saison ausgefallen in diesem
herbst sei eine impfung gegen grippe für
schwangere daher besonders wichtig so
der berufsverband der frauenärzte in
diesem jahr sei wieder mit mehr
erkrankten zu rechnen denn das
immunsystem ist erst wieder trainiert
werden außerdem falle bei 2 oder 3 g
regelungen die pflicht zum tragen der
maske weg
jetzt ein thema das für viele immer mehr
zum ärgernis wird tanken denn hohe
ölpreis und dollarkurs gehen beide nach
oben und das sorgt an den zapfsäulen für
steigende preise im september kostete
ein liter benzin durchschnittlich mehr
als 1 euro 56
und auch diese wird immer teurer im
vergangenen monat lag der liter bei rund
1 eur 41 und gestern zeiten dieselfahrer
im schnitt sogar ein eur 55 so viel wie
zuletzt 2012 simon fazit berichtet
es sind heute vor allem deutsche
kennzeichen die die tankstellen im
polnischen slubice anfahren
tanktourismus im grenzgebiet viele
fliehen vor den deutschen rekord preisen
wenn man hier mal so unrecht dass man ja
doch noch bei unter 1 40 manchmal machte
schon im oktober einer tankstelle bis
unter putz neuro meine ich ganz gut
der rentner
der dieselpreis hat ein allzeit-hoch
erreicht auch benzin wird immer teurer
die gründe global steigt der erdölpreis
außerdem ist die nachfrage nach heizöl
gerade hoch kurzfristig sehen experten
nur wenige möglichkeiten um den
rekordpreisen zu entkommen das hängt von
der persönlichen situation ab zum teil
kann man stark ins home office gehen zum
teil kann man auch den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr gehen wenn man diese
möglichkeit nicht hat dann wird man
temporär zumindest erstmal diese preise
auch zahlen müssen ein großer teil
dieser preise sind steuern und abgaben
beim diesel fallen pro liter etwa 25
cent mehrwertsteuer an 47 cent
mineralölsteuer der neue co2 preis macht
sechs bis acht cent aus da dürfe es
jetzt in den ampel verhandlungen keine
erhöhungen geben fordert der adac aus
sicht des adac muss dringend mehr tempo
gemacht werden bei den alternativen
damit die menschen eine chance haben dem
druck auszuweichen also dem preisdruck
auszuweichen und dann muss man
bevölkerungsgruppen die besonders
betroffen sind tatsächlich auch
entlasten und hier denken wir
insbesondere an pendler im moment hilft
vielen pendler nur der blick auf die uhr
abends zu tanken ist meist günstiger als
am morgen so eine aktuelle auswertung
und weitere tipps dazu wie sie beim
tanken geld sparen können und welche
apps dabei helfen haben wir für sie
online in unserer zdf heute app
zusammengefasst
der belarussische machthaber lukaschenko
sei nichts anderes als der chef eines
staatlichen schleuserring so
bundesaußenminister maß der lukaschenko
lasse gezielt geflüchtete vom nahen
osten über belarus an eu-außengrenze
bringen als rache für verschärfte
sanktionen
inzwischen überqueren täglich rund 500
menschen die grenze zwischen belarus und
polen die meisten von ihnen kommen aus
dem irak oder syrien viele wollen nach
deutschland
die polizei registrierte an der deutsch
polnischen grenze über 4.700 unerlaubte
einreisen seit august natalie steger
über die dramatische lage der
geflüchteten
völlig entkräftet gestanden im
polnischen tichy im polnischen fernsehen
berichte der privatsender tvn24 über das
schicksal der familie syrien über
belarus nach polen gekommen eine
hilfsorganisation hat sie gefunden eine
ärztin die unerkannt bleiben will
berichtet eine reporterin über die
situation an der grenze
ich habe schon einiges gesehen aber so
eine humanitäre tragödie noch nicht
solche müde ausgehungerte und
unterkühlte menschen
was genau direkt an der grenze geschieht
ist unklar den polen hat den
ausnahmezustand verhängt journalisten
und helfer dürfen nicht mehr bis zur
grenze durch helfende werfen die im
polnischen grenzschutz vor flüchtlinge
nach belarus zurückzudrängen sogenannte
push back nehmen sie die menschen nicht
in einrichtungen auf sondern schieben
sie in einen lkw und fahren sie nach
belarus zurück gut 400 kilometer ist die
polnische grenze zu belarus lang
stacheldraht liegt seit wochen jetzt
will warschau eine feste grenzanlage
bauen hilfe von der europäischen
grenzschutzagentur frontex lehnt polen
ab
wir fragen niemanden wie wir unsere
ostgrenze schützen sollen die
gleichzeitig die ostgrenze der eu ist es
ist ein kampf gegen die zeit um nicht
bald hier über leichen zu stolpern was
bald kommt weil der winter kommt
polen schützt seine eu-außengrenze doch
weil wir der medien hilfsorganisationen
noch frontex einblick haben sichert nur
wenig darüber durch wie hart der
grenzschutz durchgreift
facebook-welt 10.000 arbeitsplätze in
der eu schaffen in den kommenden fünf
jahren hoch qualifizierte ingenieure
sollen helfen das sogenannte metaversum
aufzubauen metaversum setzt sich
zusammen aus meter also jenseits und
universum und bezieht sich auf die
virtuelle welt klingt abstrakt wir
zeigen ihnen daher mal konkret warum die
virtuelle realität ein großes
zukunftsthema ist anhand eines beispiels
aus hamburg sein regen in den alten
gemäuern der hamburger speicherstadt hat
die virtuelle revolution im kleinen
schon stattgefunden das sogenannte
headquarter für virtuelle realität ist
eine touristenattraktion
konzertbesuch hamburg rundflug auf
kleinem raum ist eine eigene digitale
welt entstanden es ist schon so wenn man
eine zeitlang sich dann mit dieser feier
brille bewegt hatte ich schon den
eindruck man ist einfach mal in einem
anderen raum die rechenleistung hängt
hier unter der decke facebook möchte das
eleganter lösen vr brillen gekoppelt ans
handy und dann eintauchen in ein eigenes
universum das metaversum in dem der user
zum künstler wird einkaufen kann oder
löcher auf dem mond bohrt das nämlich
gibt es alles schon das ist meine idee
gewesen dass ich in der virtuellen welt
herum fliegen kann und spaß haben kann
auf der anderen seite dann eine firma
wie feste länder steht die wirklich sehr
klare ziele hat was dass die
datensammlung haben da läuten das schon
sind kalt den rücken runter mark
zuckerberg hatte in den vergangenen zwei
wochen viele schlechte nachrichten zu
verkraften wohl auch deshalb ließ er
heute die job offensive für europa
verkünden für branchenkenner ein
ablenkungsmanöver
wir sollten als europäer uns erst mal
zurückhalten und abwarten was wirklich
von facebook geboten wird und facebook
dazu anhalten dass sie unsere gesetze
einhalten insbesondere die
datenschutzgesetze aber auch die steuern
hier in deutschland zahlen zumal
facebook in einer selbst geschaffenen
virtuellen welt ungefiltert daten
sammeln könnte und damit der neuen
technik einen schlechten ruf verpasst
auch deshalb hoffen die startups des
hamburger headquarters dass das
metaversum noch länger auf sich warten
lässt
der ehemalige us außenminister colin
powell war ein eher gemäßigte
republikaner jetzt ist im alter von 84
jahren gestorben
paul war 2001 der erste schwarze
außenminister der usa unter präsident
george hw bush eine historische lüge ist
dann paul hängengeblieben sein auftritt
vor dem un sicherheitsrat 2003 mit
gefälschten hinweisen auf
massenvernichtungswaffen versuchte er
andere länder vom irak-krieg zu
überzeugen paul nannte das später den
schandfleck in seinem lebenslauf
das mahnmal gleis 17 am bahnhof berlin
grunewald erinnert an die grausame
deutsche geschichte des
nationalsozialismus von hier
deportierten die nazis systematisch
jüdischen menschen mit einer
gedenkveranstaltung wurde heute an die
abfahrt des ersten rotation service vor
genau 80 jahren erinnert bundespräsident
steinmeier mahnte vor einem
wiedererstarken des antisemitismus
alleine aus berlin wurden mehr als
50.000 juden den arbeits und
konzentrationslager verschleppt
anderthalb jahre waren die unis in
deutschland wegen corona verweist jetzt
geht es wieder richtig los mit
präsenzveranstaltungen
großartige nachricht für alle
studierenden aber mit einem pferdefuß
denn wer vor ort studiert braucht auch
ein zimmer und erst zweit und dritt
semester drängen gleichzeitig in die
städte aber das angebot das ist knapp
die wohnheimplätze reichen derzeit nicht
einmal für zehn prozent der
hochschülerinnen und hochschülerschaft
ist die lage in teuren städten wie
frankfurt am main so seiner santino
britta harris hatte sich den start in
ihr geschichtsstudium in frankfurt
wahrlich anders vorgestellt
doch die kölnerin mond bis heute in
einem hotelzimmer dass ihre eltern
bezahlen obwohl sie sich schon vor
vielen monaten die von der uni empfohlen
für ein zimmer in einem
studentenwohnheim bewahrt
da habe ich mich schon beworben obwohl
ich noch gar nicht wusste ob ich
überhaupt genommen werde an der uni was
ja ich total waren sind in das man
bewirbt sich auf etwas wo man noch nicht
einmal weiß ob man da jemals landen wird
ja aber da habe ich bis jetzt halt auch
noch keine antwort fehlende
wohnheimplätze sind im großen städten
bundesweit ein problem doch in der
bankenstadt frankfurt besonders nur 45
prozent studierende könne ein platz in
einem wohnheim bekommen 2500 gehen leer
aus
romero hat ein zimmer im wohnheim akad
für ein wg-zimmer hätte die
jurastudentin rund 600 euro bezahlt aber
auch das ist schwer zu bekommen es sind
mehr als 20 30 interessenten plötzlich
an einer wohnung und da als student
nochmal durchzukommen ist sehr sehr
schwierig auch das land hessen insgesamt
steht bei den wohnheimplätzen für
studierende mit 73 prozent eher
schlechter platz 13 im bundesweiten
vergleich in den letzten zehn jahren
seien aber 3000 neue wohnheimplätze
geschaffen worden sagt der
wirtschaftsminister also wir holen auf
das studierendenwerk sagt wir sind platz
eins bei den aufholen also plus 20
prozent seit 2000 13 aber wir haben auch
noch viel zu tun britta herres hofft
dass sie bald doch noch einen platz im
wohnheim oder ein günstiges wg zimmer
bekommt täglich von köln nach frankfurt
pendeln will sie auf keinen fall und das
hotelzimmer ist auf dauer zu teuer
für sechs autorinnen und autoren war
dieser abend besonders spannend denn
ihre bücher standen auf der sogenannten
shortlist für den deutschen buchpreis
mit dem der beste roman in diesem jahr
ausgezeichnet wird verliehen wird er
immer zum auftakt der frankfurter
buchmesse und die ausgezeichneten bücher
verkaufen sich meist bestens heute
konnte sich antje rávic strubel über den
preis freuen ihr roman blaue frau gewann
michael klinger hat mehr
die gewinnerin des deutschen buchpreises
scheint es kaum zu fassen acht jahre hat
die autorin an jedem buch geschrieben
nun diese große auszeichnung
farbige strobl vermag
essayistische passagen
einfließen zu lassen in ihren text sehr
gute dialoge eine sehr spannende
geschichte zu erzählen bei der man bis
zum ende mit der figur der weiblichen
hauptfigur mitfiebert antje rávic
strubel schreibt über adina eine junge
frau aus tschechien die es in die ferne
zieht sie hat sich in helsinki in einem
plattenbau zurückgezogen unsichtbar
gemacht so heißt es im roman sie lebt
mit einem trauma ein kulturpolitiker hat
sie als praktikantin in deutschland
vergewaltigt im buch geht es um
machtgefälle auch zwischen ost und
westeuropa die schwere geschichte ist
einfühlsam und mitreißend erzählt
wehre dich daran arbeitete filme eben
immer häufiger auf dass es
offensichtlich
extrem viele fälle von sexuellen
missbrauch gibt gewalt gegen frauen gibt
wenn nicht die erste der das auffällt
aber mir fehlt das auf weil es weil es
in meinem umfeld irgendwie plötzlich so
oder mehr und mehr jung wie zutage trat
die konkurrenz war wieder stark mitunter
den letzten sechs unter anderem der
bestseller autor christian kracht die
blaue frau hat sich durchgesetzt und
jetzt zum sport das gesicht zur stimme
norbert ist neben mir hallo und fc
bayern münchen hast du mitgebracht haben
wir gezeigt ja und das war natürlich ein
harter schlag für bayer leverkusen wer
erwartet hatte dass der rekordmeister
beim verfolger straucheln würde den
bewährten lewandowski capri und co beim
5 zu 1 eines besseren der fcb bleibt
titelkandidat nummer eins
überflieger bayern münchen der meister
dominiert verfolger leverkusen bayer nur
sparringspartner die münchner mit
einstudierten abläufen und einem
treffsicheren robert lewandowski
leverkusen immer zu spät dran bayern hat
spaß und freude und einen doppelpack
lewandowski zum zweiten der meister
trifft wie er will und fast immer
unbedrängt auch müller ziemlich allein
insgesamt finde ich aber in den punkten
immer gegen frankfurt ich super gemacht
haben heute extreme schritte gemacht
weil wir sehr stabil apropos extrem die
bemerkenswerte beinfreiheit nutzt auch
gabi und zwar zweimal 15 0 zur pause
höchste bayern halbzeitführung der
bundesliga-geschichte leverkusen nur
noch mit ergebniskosmetik 1 zu 5 der
endstand die bayern aber fahren gut
gelaunt zur champions league nach
lissabon
alle tore von allen partien des achten
spieltages können sie sich bei uns noch
einmal anschauen wie immer online
zusammengefasst auf zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app so bleiben sie immer
am ball
borussia dortmund ist froh torjäger
erling hollern wieder am start zu haben
haben samstag schon wieder zwei treffer
des norwegers gegen mainz ähnliches
erhoffen sie beim bvb für das champions
league duell morgen bei tabellenführer
ajax amsterdam
erling holland hat sich nochmal so
richtig aufgepumpt mit selbstbewusstsein
für seine mitspieler ist er passt scho
deh größter new jetzt nur leider ihn als
stürmer schiesst gehört er sicherlich zu
den top 3 der welt ajax hat mit
sebastian er aber den führenden der
champions league torschützenliste fünf
treffer allein vier davon den lissabon
wo sein ganzes team begeisterte
natürlich spaß ihnen zuzuschauen
es wird für uns morgen schon eine große
herausforderung dort in amsterdam heute
trainierten sie noch in dortmund bevor
es mit dem bus nach amsterdam ging
ja große meint das ist eine gut geölte
mannschaft ajax hat nicht hier
und jetzt gehts nach olympia und santi
kolumbien den will sie jetzt auch mit
denn dort ging heute das olympische
feuer auf die reise 100 tage vor den
winterspielen peking wurde die flamme im
heiligen hain ganz klassisch mit
sonnenkraft und ein parabolspiegel
kein problem bei 20 grad und strahlend
blauem himmel über nacht bleibt die
fackel auf der akropolis in athen
dann aber geht es los auf die lange
reise nach china
noch das wetter turbulent wird die
wetter woche erst kommt regen dann wird
es ungewöhnlich mild und schließlich
stürmt details gleich von katja honnefer
marietta slomka hat um 21.45 das
heute-journal für sie macht es gut
[Musik]
guten abend das wird wirklich eine
turbulente woche
da kommen jetzt erst mal regen wolken
von westen heran und dann wird es bei
uns richtig stürmisch zuvor aber sehr
mild heute gab es noch mal so ein
wechselspiel aus nebel und sonnenschein
mit sonnenschein kletterten die
temperaturen hier in oberstdorf bis auf
18 grad im nebel gab es dagegen kaum 10
grad in norddeutschland war es eher
stärker bewölkt bis bedeckt und hiervon
westen werden die wolken jetzt dichter
und bringen in der nacht zwischen den
ostfriesischen inseln der mosel auch
regen sonst bleibt es trocken und in
bayern bildet sich nebel die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht auf
3 10 bis 4 grad und liegen morgen recht
ungewöhnlich hoch mit 16 bis 20 grad
ganz verbreitet in deutschland nur
zwischen den nordhessischen bergland und
den bayerischen wald und im nordosten
bleibt es bei 12 bis 15 grad etwas
kühler der regen der nacht zieht weiter
nach osten wird den äußersten osten aber
nicht erreichen und im südwesten lockern
die wolken am späten nachmittag schon
wieder auf und dann kommt der stoff
hendrik heißt er bringt kräftige
sturmböen an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee dazu gibt es schauer und gewitter
davor wird es noch mal richtig warm bis
zu 23 grad in zwickau oder chemnitz und
sehr wechselhaft und stürmisch geht es
danach weiter guten abend